As a Galician MEP
I called for this debate
in the face of the environmental catastrophe of the tide of films
that flooded the coast of my country.
Galicia
it is not only 1 Galician problem,
it is 1 European problem.
As we discussed with you today,
Commissioner,
December 8 was the accident,
13 the first pellets arrive,
January 04.
Galician government addresses the concellos
almost 1 month later
to tell them that it was their responsibility
cleaning the beaches.
In the face of the innation of the Galician government
had to clean alone,
feeling abandoned and.
I take the opportunity to greet the mayor of the walls,
Maria Lago,
who is in the rostrum,
example of dignity,
together with the mayor of Ribeira
and volunteers in the fight against this tragedy
ecological.
Thanks to MEPs from 5 groups
politicians for having signed the letter that we will be sending you
Commissioner,
galiza is not soa,
the Gállego government
took 1 month to activate the anti-pollution plan
and alert 2,
this is 1 obvious case of catastrophe denial.
One need only listen to the gentlemen of
and PP ladies
who repeat slogans that come from Galicia
of improvisation,
manipulation,
of negligence in management and lack of transparency.
PP government calls it plastic balls
more than 1,000 bags from Perez
that do not stop arriving on our coast.
How little yesdoe,
what incompetence.
Galicia is 1 Mexican nation,
with marine resources
and unique biodiversity.
This organic pollution affects the 2nd Seaman,
and of course
can affect the way of life.
The fishing and shellfishing sector,
to whom I transfer all of Venega's support.
The PP government prefers them
for 14 years,
that does cost the fishing sector.
of the PP,
don't come here to try to divert attention
as they do in tvga.
That Sunday there is 1 demonstration in Santiago,
including the fishing sector,
with more than 100 groups supporting them.
But this mismanagement is not new,
reminds us of the disaster,
They have not discovered anything.
Your brazenness is Tal
that Asunta commissioned 1 marketing company
linked to the PP part of the cleaning of the pellets,
you will be given 1 yunta sweater.
And if you want to pick up the peels,
so much the better.
They said,
what the Galego government does not do,
we do it here,
us and us,
claiming to consider the skins as dangerous goods
to avoid accidental losses,
consider them contaminants
in the New microplastic loss regulation,
because Galicia cannot be the pourer of Europe,
deserves more.
It is above all 1 responsible government